so the first thing I want to do is
introduce director Todd Strauss schulson
and yes big
Applause do you know why I put an
emphasis on your name no you really
don't I'm so happy you don't remember
this I'm going to out myself right now
so I moderate a lot of Live q&as And I'm
really grateful for it I love it so much
do you know what the very first one I
ever moderated was it was in the Apple
Store for this movie with you and and
the first thing I did when I name wrong
I like spoonerism your last name I they
called you like Todd schulen Strauss or
so I don't know but I got it right now I
remember that day that was after a long
day of doing like ComicCon and press and
I hadn't eaten and I was like falling
apart on stage okay well I was so I was
a little crabby I don't think you were
crabby I just thought I sucked but I
swear I've gotten better in the last all
right the same wavelength I promise I
have better questions this time around I
want to go back to the very very
beginning of your directing Journey when
you first started did you ever imagine
yourself working in the horror genre hi
everybody thank you for showing up on
the Friday night of Halloween I um yeah
I did I grew up in Queens I wanted to
make movies my whole life and my thing
was that I went I would grew up in an
apartment building next to a video store
and I made it I thought my job in high
school is going to be to watch every
movie in this store in a row I started
from left to right and I thought I would
just do that but then every four months
they changed the store around and it
[__] me up so suddenly fantasy is
where horror was anyways I watched every
movie and I loved horror movies I was
really scared of horror movies at first
and then I realized that people were
making them and so all the blood and
gore and that was Tom SV and all these
guys and I wrote away I had a
correspondence with Dick Smith when I
was like 13 and 14 and I was doing
liquid latex I thought I would be a
makeup effects artist that's what I
thought I would be first and then I
realized no I just love these movies and
I love Nightmare on elem street and
three and four and and then and then so
yeah I loved horror movies and I loved
blood and shed I have two follow-up
questions what was the first horror
movie that scared you but then I also
want to know what the first horror movie
that you saw that like scared you but
also made you appreciate that thrill and
made you say I want to make things like
that and give people those feelings the
best thing about q&a's is I know all the
A's I know them I know the answers to
those questions my uh what was the
question the first one scared me first
movie that legitimately scared you kept
you up was such a I was such a wimpy
sensitive boy that um you ever see
Fright Night Fright night's like not
scary but to me it was so scary isn't
that why you included the poster in the
movie that's one of the reasons but also
we had like a choice of six posters that
were legal to use but this that one
really scared me and watching it now as
an adult it's like not a scary movie but
that really got me house and house too
got me so scared and then I think it was
Nightmare in El Street 3 and four I was
like these are just delightful and
they're a little silly but they're so
full of ination visually their bananas
and music video directors made those
movies and then I was like okay I can
like check this out and just enjoy what
this is and how did they do that and it
was all so Technical and that was
exciting and now you made a horror
comedy that Delights everybody so you
took a queue from them and you ran with
it I want to go back to a very Harold
and Kumar Christmas briefly so that it's
retrospective that movie that movie come
kind of it leads into final girls that
movie comes out and I feel like
immediately after that movie came out it
was announced that you were directing
this movie but then this movie didn't go
into production until 2014 so it's a
jump from 2011 to
2014 what took so long and can you give
us a little insight into how difficult
it can be to get a feature of green
light yeah it took that long I mean if
the internet is correct now the internet
is always correct right yeah um so okay
A a long answer to a short question I it
is true I made harn Kumar Christmas
first three months before I made that
movie my father died and so then I went
immediately into making a movie which
was my dream from when I was 5 years old
so that was obviously a very intense
thing to have happened in your life and
then right when I finished when I was
editing Harold and Kumar Mark and Josh
who wrote this movie Mark I went to
college with I was friends with them for
they were couple I was friends with them
all through you know getting out of
college and the 10 years before I made a
movie and they had pitched me final
girls like eight years before we made it
this just as an idea what if kids got
stuck in a bad horror movie that was
sort of basically the idea then I never
heard anything else about that and then
my father and then I make this movie and
then they send me the first draft right
after while I'm editing and I read it
and it was very it was different but the
idea was the idea it was kids are in a
movie and also there's a dead parent and
a chance to be with a dead parent and I
read it and I was like I get this movie
like it's not just a comedy and it's not
a horror movie it's about another chance
one more day with a parent saving a
parent from death and Josh you know the
story I don't know if you know this but
Josh who wrote the movie his father was
um played father Caris in The Exorcist
and he died and Josh's experience and
why he wanted to write this was because
the only way that he could re-experience
his dad was by watching The Exorcist and
watching his dad get murdered over and
over which was a pretty morbid way to
remember your dad and so that's where
the movie came from and so I read it
afterwards I was like I got to do this
and I got involved and then we redid the
script we wrote it together and it took
forever to get the money this was before
this is pr- stranger things and this is
before this was happy death day there
those movies were not didn't exist yet
so doing something in this genre was um
not scary to
financiers um
and and The Meta part didn't help and
also we were going around pitching it as
Terms of Endearment means Friday the
13th and people were like what what we
don't know what that is so we had to
stop doing that and it took and it took
a while and but eventually we muscled
our way into someone giving us $5
million to do it we had 26 days to do it
was there anything specific you yeah
that's what I said when they told me
that too was there anything specific you
changed in that pitch that you noticed
like really sparked with people no I
think we we had maybe two people that
wanted to do it and neither were great
and one of the places said do it but
it's got to do it the PG-13 question I
know is coming but one of the places
said you got to make a PG-13 and maybe
they're um aliens and maybe they Bleed
Blue and that's how we can give you the
money and I was like well certainly it's
not going to be you giving us the money
for this so he went with the other place
and took it and took it chance okay and
the I mean the PG-13 rating does work I
know you weren't really into the idea
when that demand was made but it does
feel like like this to me feels like the
perfect movie that appeals to people who
have loved this type of horror their
entire lives but can also serve as a
horror Gateway for a bunch of people who
want to just tiptoe into the genre and
see what it's about I think it's true
did who here did anyone wish that it was
way gorier you can be honest really one
yeah so yeah that's fair I mean I
figured more I will tell you that when
they said we'll give you the money and
you can have freedom to do it but it's
got to be PG-13 all of us were pissed we
didn't think we didn't want to do it we
it was written to be disgusting we we
movies like Dead Alive and bad taste you
know like we were there Tina's bre there
was a thing her breast got chopped up
and they're flying around and it was it
was really disgusting I mean there was
it was were going hard at the gore and
then they said either do it PG-13 or you
don't have a movie to make and I said
well it's better to have one but I will
tell you
that once we started making it and once
we started to edit it and it became
pretty clear that for a movie that is
about grief and a movie where you want
to feel every kill and you want to fall
in love with all those characters even
the dumb charact movie characters Adam
Divine like you kind of like that guy
that you you really are telling a story
about grief in a genre that doesn't take
death very seriously and so if the
filmmakers were blood Lusty you know and
like relishing and how disgusting I
think that it wouldn't work and I bet
when we were editing it we would have
ended up making it like this anyways
even if they didn't make us do it I
would totally believe that all right
let's go back to the script briefly what
would you say is the biggest difference
between that very first draft of it you
read and the final film we all watch in
now the um there were a lot of
differences I mean uh the the first
draft of the film had was had a lot more
characters in it and it wasn't a comedy
and there wasn't that much meta stuff in
it you know getting stuck in the movie
and looping and 92 minutes later that
stuff wasn't really there they were in
the the idea that the movie would be an
antagonist was not in there and so those
are ideas that I brought to it I was
like we'll make it funny and meta and
all and the Back to the Future feeling
of it the pleasant real feeling of it
was a kind of something I tried to bring
and we did a lot of different draft to
the script and it went through many
iterations it was at new line for a
there was a million different versions
of the script which probably would took
so long and there was a version that I
thought was this is the version and that
version had a lot of meta stuff in it
there was [__] in it that I thought was
so good and it was like at the end that
the big final fight happened like on the
credits as they were so they were like
hanging from letters and letters were
falling and they were maching as they
were getting farther from the ground I
was like that would be a cool sequence
do that with the budget you had right
definitely not and also there was an
idea of in the middle when everyone die
when um when the final girl dies and the
car blows up that there was an idea that
everyone died and then the whole movie
would begin again and now our kids would
be the counselors in the movie and I was
like that's a [__] clever idea this
is cool but then and we were like we
worked so hard on that draft and we
turned it in and everyone was like what
happened to the heart there's no feeling
in this anymore it's just so clever and
so there was this whole long process of
figuring out the balance of all that the
comedy and The Meta but also making sure
that you felt and there was a heart and
that by the end you would cry which is
what we all wanted for sure very very
success I've seen this movie more times
than I can count and uh the end of this
movie makes me c like not even just tear
up like actually sit in a puddle of
Tears every single time I watch
it so let's go to your cast of all the
characters in this movie which character
was the easiest to cast where like the
right person just like magically
appeared past let's go to your past I
mean we can if you want to discuss your
past this could be a therapy session uh
no I did that today
already um easiest to cast was Adam and
Thomas I was was friends with Adam and
Thomas in my life and I gave Thomas the
script and I said who do you want to be
and he said I'll be that guy and I said
that's easy and then Adam I had known
also from something else and I thought
he would be I obviously that seemed like
the perfect role for Adam at the time
and he was like absolutely so those were
the two easiest to cast and then I need
the opposite the most difficult role to
find the perfect fit for the mother and
daughter that was so hard and there were
a million versions of it because it took
so long to get the money we were casting
throughout and so we had people in and
they would fall out and then we had to
find combinations of people that made
sense together and it it and it just was
this whole thing where the movie was
together and then someone left and then
the other person didn't work and all
this stuff and but we landed on to where
obviously you always the answer is that
you couldn't imagine it with anybody
else and so and it was amazing aming
actually because
taisa is so was so young and she hadn't
been in a lot of movies and so that
she's sort of the anchor of the whole
movie but she's like cellophane thin
like she's so sensitive and fragile in
it you know like for me at least when I
watch it I'm like Jesus Christ you can
feel the grief just coming out of her
and so she I think anchors it and then
Molen is she's funny when she's sweet
but in malin's real life months before
the movie she had just had a child she
had an infant onset so she had just
become a mother for the first time and
her marriage imploded so she was
suddenly a single mother with an infant
and that is what she walked on to set
with from her life so she didn't have to
do so much so when she's saying goodbye
to her daughter when she's in that blue
room saying that I love you and I could
be anything I want to be all that hope
and all that pain is is is real for her
and so for all of us this movie was very
special and unique it's crazy that it's
still being screened all this time later
but there was something that was alive
on I think about it I have to I talk
about it all the time still but there
was something I think alive for like
everyone somehow and you could feel that
I think when they're together you you
feel it when you're watching the movie
for sure I don't want to leave the the
cast just yet and this is something I
always love asking about because I love
how every actor out there has a
different approach to the work can you
maybe pinpoint two members of this
Ensemble with completely different
approaches to their work where it
demands something totally different from
you as their actor's
director the work yeah well I would yeah
okay I know the answer to that
question I think you know the a um they
I would I mean the tone of the movie was
built into the casting that's kind of
was the idea and so the it's part really
funny and part sort of sweet and
grounded there's a little bit of
melodrama in there so like nah and
Alexander kind of bring a little bit of
that soapy stuff and then obviously
there's all the comic actors and then
there's Mar and TAA and so like Thomas
and Adam and Alia were improving all the
time most of that stuff is improvised we
had great jokes and they did things but
a lot so much of that gay dads I mean
all many many things you could probably
feel were made up on the spot when you
have people like that together that just
sort of happens nah showed up thinking
she was in a comedy and she had super
and she' never done comedy so she super
overprepared a comedy performance so on
the first day she showed up she had a
binder of things that were high liid
with accents and that was and I don't
know who taught her how to do that but
that was not helpful and so it was like
action and she said something like she
was not from this country trying to do
comedy do you know it all
sounded pushed and I was like what is he
what is you what are you trying to do
and so she had to throw that book away
and play and just be like just be real
like don't like throw everything away
don't try to sell a joke that isn't your
job and it'll be much funnier if you
don't so that would maybe be an example
of that and she's so good in the final
film and I just saw her do another
comedy with uh Adam and she's funny that
the Outlaws it's fun yeah she's funny
she's good all right let's go to Billy
now specifically The Mask because the
mask in a slasher movie is of the utmost
importance what was it like pinpointing
the right look is this what you had in
mind from the start or did that evolve
the
the it was hard coming up with a mask
that you hadn't seen in a horror movie
The Burning obviously and Friday were
movies that we were like that's pretty
iconic what can we do that feels like
that but isn't that and we thought totem
you know sort of something from totem
poles would make sense and would and
that kind of thing but we we had an
amazing production designer and an
amazing art team and they were tasked
with doing it but they were not horror
people and the mask was very silly for a
very long time it was hard to get it to
be scary it was like the eyes had to be
dead and it had to have not that many
features that's kind of what's good
about Jason but it had the totem thing
and I remember and they would do show
ints and there was the funniest [__]
they had worked so hard on it the thing
had B eyebrows and it it was like kind
of it looked was and it looked like
Eugene
Levy they showed it to me and I was like
that's Eugene Levy what is this can't be
right and it just we had it it was it
was but it was a process of simplifying
the mask and trying not to light it you
know too brightly and to make it scary
that version of The Mask in the movie
isn't there one alt version that is
actually in a shot here oh man how do
you know that I I've obsessed over your
movie since 2015 I think that I didn't
know that until you just said that I
think I actually know the specific shot
too it's in the window it's in the
window yeah it's in the window because
we had to shoot that before they fixed
the mask that's the Eugene lovey
version that's so funny I remember
that's why he's behind those curtains
got to watch the movie again so you can
overanalyze it like I did behind the
curtain because you're like we can't put
this
in another Billy question did uh Josh
and Mark ever tell you why they chose
the name Billy Murphy no I'm just
curious you know why I have no clue why
I mean it does like it sounds like a
slasher name I don't know it's like
those it's like Friday it's like just
something like whatever Podunk name that
could be completely agnostic and seems
not scary but it's scary that works yeah
all right broader question now of all of
the Epic set pieces in this movie going
into filming which did you think would
be the most difficult to pull off and
then ultimately was that indeed the
hardest or did another one Catch You by
surprise great question Perry and I have
the answer believe it or not I've been
waiting for you to say that to me since
2015 great question you're doing you're
doing great isn't she doing great she's
doing so good she's so good she loves
movies don't go Google the 2015 Q&A
please yeah I haven't eaten that I'm
snippy um the I the the operation booby
trap sequence which is the one where
people where everyone's dying and it
feels like a panic attack in the cabin
and the camera's spinning all over that
was the one this movie cost such a
little amount of money we had to really
be smart about where how we were putting
using the money and that was a sequence
we like well the movie changes here
people are dying and we're going into
night the the crew is thinning out and
things are getting real so I wanted to
make that a thing and we shot it with a
motion control camera and I had this
idea of doing these long crazy
impossible camera moves and so that's
that's like a robot camera on tracks and
so that was a whole thing and I had to
get everyone on board to do it we built
that
cabin from scratch and we built it to
spec to fit for an inch just as much
room as we needed for the motion control
camera so that was just like that and I
thought that that would be a really hard
sequence um we had previsit it we had
rehearsed it a lot of times we had one
night to do it it was raining we was we
were in Baton Rouge it was muggy and
pouring rain and so we all were stuck in
the house together and we shot that but
that was so I thought that was going to
be a really stressful and hard thing to
do and it was every day was stressful we
were defined gravity every day obviously
we didn't have any time or or anything
but that sequence I thought was going to
be the hardest it was not the hardest
because we had been so planned about it
and the actors knew there was a previous
they were like just do that you got to
be there when on this moment and then be
gone that like so that went pretty good
what surprised me was the fire sequence
that I was like yeah we have these crazy
stunt Guys these cinjun stunt guys that
seem to be afraid of nothing and they'll
do anything I say that car blew up that
was like napom that was much bigger than
we anticipated and I thought that that
would be an easier sequence I just
figured that's a stunt and we'll have
three cameras going and why not that was
the craziest [__] night that was our
last night at this we were in a all
girls sleep away summer camp in Baton
Rouge it was I think it was a Christian
summer camp in Baton Rouge we D we had
destroyed the camp our trucks were
driving over pipes and septic tanks were
leaking we' [__] the whole place up this
was the last night we were at the camp
and we had to do the fire and the the
Cajun stunk guys forgot the [__] that
puts the guy out they only had enough of
that for like one for two Burns I was
like you forgot this stuff they're like
yeah like well can you go home and get
the stuff and they're like home is like
three hours away I was like you've been
driving three hours every day to get
this so we can only do it twice so one
burn was him jumping out of the window
which we did with three cameras and that
was great and then we had to do that
whole running sequence um with three
cameras and as the sun was coming up and
it was so stressful because if you don't
get it I guess you don't get it what are
we going to do and we had to leave the
camp and so it was the final night the
crew was together people came out of the
trucks and the hair and makeup and
everyone set their chairs up and had
popcorn and sodas it was like 4:00 or 5
in the morning it was like there was an
audience of the movie watching us shoot
the last shots of the movie which was
felt great obviously and it was sad to
leave the camp we had been there we all
felt like campers and then it was like
and action we had like two lights we had
like AC and they're running and
everyone's doing it and F you know what
a focus puller is we're in Los Angeles
pulling focus on that long lens at night
with four people and fire and they're
running full speed that is a [__]
impossible task to nail that we didn't
know if we were going to get it and they
did it and cut and we did playback
holding our breath and we watched it and
the focus puller was like on the edge of
the seat and he [__] nailed it we
were like this is unbelievable you could
use this shot top to bottom and the
whole crew applauded for the focus
puller yeah like this and the sun came
up and four buses of seven-year-old
girls showed up and we had to go home
and that was how we ended the the
shooting of the
movie I'm glad you shout out your focus
polar Focus pullers ads they all need
more credit than they ever get they need
more credit magicians magicians hero
that night here's one thing I was eager
to ask you about because I always love
an opportunity to demystify re-shoot and
additional photography because they have
a negative connotation and they
shouldn't they're an important part of
the process so what is something you
learned in early test screenings of the
movie that you were able to address and
now we can see it in the finished cut
and it makes the movie better the
um we okay we didn't have a lot of money
for many re-shoot and we only did one
test and we learned in the test it was
helpful actually we learned in the test
that people fell in love with that
friend group and the original ending we
only did one re-shoot which was the
ending and the original ending was that
everyone really did die and only Max and
Alexander lwig surv five and they're in
the hospital and that whole thing with
the sequel that was all the same but it
was only the two of them and they were
going to have to get stuck in the sequel
together and we learned is oh wait so
everyone really died that's so sad we
want to see them back together again and
also maybe touch the mom one more time
in the real world and so that's what we
reshot we reshot
um yeah the friends in the hospital and
that was it good choice if anyone wants
to see the original ending you can buy
the movie and it's one of the deleted
scenes
that is true the DVD is stacked full of
stuff and you can also buy a DVD player
for
$40 I mean you could buy it digitally
and get access to the bonus features too
if you prefer um speaking about that
ending has there ever been an actual
conversation about making a sequel yeah
but believe it or not the movie didn't
make enough money to Warrant one though
it somehow has has this life of its own
and every year it's screened at houses
like this but we did we had a good idea
they tried to do it as a TV show once we
had a good idea for a sequel all the
actors would love to do it but what's
final girls I like to take these
collider interview opportunities as h a
chance to maybe manifest something so I
would like a sequel I also like the idea
of it being meta and you making a sequel
so many years later where you could
tackle a different generation of horror
movies and have new things to say I feel
like that's that's why scream keeps
coming back and back and having more
things to say about horror yeah I mean
the vague idea that Josh and Mark had
was that they would be out in the real
world and Billy the actor who played
Billy Murphy was the dad and so it would
be about her and her dad in the real
world and all the other actors are now
old and shitty and like whatever and but
but real Billy's in the real world so
real Billy and actor Billy have to Duke
it out in the real world all this [__]
stuff
and there would be horror conventions
and you would be yeah that you need to
just keep talking about it and I'll keep
celebrating we'll all come back here
every year until this movie happen if
anyone uh was at the trick-or treat Q&A
last week apparently Mike Doty likes to
sacrifice goats and then that makes his
horror making uh horror movie making
Ambitions happen so what we could do
that do you know what she's talking
about or you're just going to gloss some
people know some people know if you know
you know what oh he was kidding of
course he was
kidding you're talking to somebody who
would literally watch anybody die in a
horror movie except for an animal it is
always a joke all right before I throw
it to the audience I told you we were
going to play a little game this one of
my favorite games to play it's our
slasher movie uh Survival Game I am
going to give you character superlatives
and I want you to tell me which actor
from the movie like the ACT not the
character they play best suits this
description all right first one who is
most likely to not realize that they're
in a horror movie go and investigate a
strange noise and be the first to die
and be the first to die
Adam believe that no he's not dumb but
yeah maybe
Adam who would be most likely to
sacrifice themselves to the others menen
okay I would also believe that most
likely to trip in fall while running
from the killer
Adam so again he's the first to die most
likely to be the first to figure
everything out and give the group a
Fighting Chance Alia okay who's smart
enough to leave right at the start be
like something's not going right I got
to get out of here and actually leave
Angela dber okay she's an empath she's a
water sign she can feel it who's most
like to be the last one standing uh
probably Nina okay I was going to say
maybe taisa I feel like she knows what
she's doing at this point maybe TAA I
believe in herina last one who is most
likely to be the one that everyone
thinks is dead but comes back at the
last possible second to save the day
Adam I feel like this is a movie idea
like he dies first and you think he's
dead the whole movie but like Adam
playing Adam comes back at the last last
possible second I would watch this movie
all right so now we're going to take
some audience questions and then we will
do our poster giveaway firsthand right
in the middle in the
back um this is more of a common passing
on a message uh Darren demetry wanted me
to tell you to shake and bake oh man how
do you know him uh my dad that Darren's
your dad oh my God Darren was our um
produ line producer production Darren
made that $5 million in to this movie
and he tried to shut me down constantly
and I ran away from him like a squirrel
he couldn't stop me and he loves cigars
we would leave after a long day of
shooting he'd be sitting there dressed
like a camper just chomping on a cigar
and not anymore good for him those look
good for Darren all right who else right
in front of you now yeah red sweatshirt
I was gonna say did you have like
multiple scrips with like different
deaths and like different ways of people
dying
yeah yeah there yeah I mean in the
gorier versions of the scripts there
were like horrible you know there were
decapitations and you have I mean like
fake breasts were getting cut off which
is gross and bad now but um what else
was there there was I forget exactly
what there was but there was really like
straight up dead Alives like lawn mower
iny face stuff and that all had to get
tweaked so falling into a bear trap I
think was probably in one of the drafts
but it was you saw it like you saw a
bear trap just [__] eat a person and
here you kind of see but the camera sort
of flies away pretty fast um you know
was there a version of this script where
Gertie didn't want to leave and she
tried to sabotage the mission to get out
of the movie was there I don't know I
read that online again everything online
is true I don't think that she ever
sabotaged it but I think that there was
a version where she wanted to stay
because she'd fallen in love with Tori
that's really sweet but then as you're
reading it you're like who the [__]
gives a [__] about those to like you do
but they're like fifth down the totem
pole of people you have to service
that's fair so they have their kiss and
they say I love you that was a thing we
learned there was a that scene before
but when they say goodbye and they kiss
and all that that was Hil to me
hilariously like 5 minutes long and Greg
Jenkins who is here who did the music
for the movie wrote a beautiful thing
and this CRA in the middle of this crazy
sequence there was a very emotional
goodbye I love you and I'll miss you and
you're and which was kind of a joke but
also really sweet and you would screen
it and be like no one needs that also a
deleted scene people can watch that's a
good right that's that's a deleted scene
people can watch all right who else
Robin was there ever a draft in the
script where they tried to like
intervene in Billy's origin in the
flashback sequence that they tried to
save him to stop all the
murders I don't know there probably was
but it probably just pulled on so many
threads that it just [__] us up so I
think we had to invent some idea of like
you can't [__] with the ecosystem too
much otherwise when be you know what I
mean like a time travel sort of a thing
it's a good thought I saw yeah right in
the middle there um recently another
movie came out a very similar premise
called totally killer like is it weird
or flattering that such a similar movie
has come out since
then yeah it was weird I haven't seen it
I guess it's pretty different though
have you seen it who's seen it is it's
pretty different or is it very much the
same
thing it's different cuz the meta stuff
they don't get caught in a movie it's
different but on the face of it it did
sound like exactly the same movie which
was not like my favorite
feeling and blumhouse knows this this
movie exists but it's but it's different
it's different totally killer is
delightful I recommend it to anyone who
hasn't seen it it is very very different
it is not the same you know horror movie
loving meta quality at all yeah yeah
yeah the log line sounds the same but
the movie is clearly pretty different
you don't walk into a horror movie
immediately makes them very different
all right who else before all right
we'll take this question here and then
we'll do our poster giveaways uh who's
your favorite here and what's your
favorite scene and
why my favorite scene my favorite I
sometimes when I the movie screened I
come to the movie and I try to get there
for booby trap and Beyond I like that
that part of the movie really kind of
takes off for me booby trap is the
whenever everything's going bad but my
favorite scene is the goodbye scene and
um and you know it's the last question
so I'll make it emotional that we it's
Josh's dad and it's my dad and we shot
that scene and we sat in that church in
the middle of the night Baton Rouge and
when they were doing that scene our dads
were in that room and we were saying
goodbye and we were watching that
monitor and we were also crying and that
is us saying goodbye and so whenever I
see this movie that is what it means to
me that scene and it's nice to see the
movie sometimes and remember that and
say goodbye again or say hello you know
and so that's my favorite scene favorite
character oh I don't know how could you
pick just one I
I I mean I like when Thomas and Adam are
going at it that always makes me giggle
I like that stuff good answers right
there all right so I've got three
posters here these posters were made by
Daniel Spencer LaVine very talented
artist and they were made exclusively
for this screening so we only have three
three people are getting one of three
and Todd's going to sign them but I need
to make you work for it I have three
trivia questions here I'm going to make
you do a little work I'm going to read
the question and you need to tell me who
shot their hand up the first first above
everybody else love this job yeah it
gives me anxiety that's why I passed
along someone else all right first
question tdas directed Adam in two other
projects can someone name one of
them oh you is it romantic
correct okay so when we're done just
come down here will'll get you a poster
and get it signed All right so that's
one winner right there What's the title
of the camp blood bath
sequel
red blood
to us y the song
okay these are too easy now you guys are
good at this do you want to come up with
a hard
one your right on the spot like a little
like a little detail oh God ask one more
oh wait there's only no more posters
there's going to be there's going to be
one more I feel like these are easy
what's a good hard question
uh I mean I don't know the answer to
this question I have one what's yours
how long is this movie and Camp blood
bath what wait I wasn't paying attention
I saw in the red shirt in yeah you 92
minutes you got it right movies 92 both
movies are the same the same length all
right those are our three poster come
down here now get them signed and thank
you to all of you thank you for coming
to see this movie on Halloween spread
the final girls love so we can get a
sequel remember
manifesting thank you
Barry